Isaac, I've been feeling, I've been feeling for you,
because I've been thinking, it must be tough
for your character now going through life without Hodor.
Aww.
(audience awws)
Yeah, no it's--
You know, what's it, what's it been like for you?
Well I've grown up next to Kristian Nairn,
who's the actor who played Hodor for the past six years,
and so, to suddenly not have that,
literally big presence on the set has been really sad.
I miss my big, friendly giant, but I'm sure he's--
(audience cheers and applauds)
He's back (laughing) he's back.
[Conan] Wow. (laughing)
[Crowd] Hodor, Hodor, Hodor, Hodor, Hodor, Hodor.
[Conan] That was nice, I can't believe it.
I can not believe it.
Hello.
I can not believe we just had
a happy ending on Game of Thrones.
(audience cheers and laughs)
First time,
first time ever.
It brings a tear to my eye,
thank you so much for being here,
what a lovely surprise.
You're welcome man, you're welcome (laughs)
Security here stinks.
(audience laughs)